me ha gustado cerrar porque si esto
fuera vivelatino yo será caifanes
entonces tengo a todos aquí para mí
y para no variar quiero comenzar
esta plática con un poquito de la
historia que me trae aquí sí así es otra
historia de alguien que era pobre y ya
no es pobre pero es la última de la
noche no se preocupen
hace exactamente
16 años tengo 32 años por gusto a la
banda mexicana
molotov me metí
y cree su cuenta de myspace no existe a
twitter no existía facebook hoy y
escribir más de 10 libros de cómo
manejar tus redes sociales como sea un
influencers se metan al google play
ponen mi nombre y más en favor de
comprar los días en esa época no había
nada escrito los community managers no
existían no existía toda esta industria
que soy y yo hice el myspace de molotov
cuando dos años después de que yo
intuitivamente subí a lo que creía que
debía llevar un myspace que era donde
iban a tocar si ya tocaron las
fotografías de donde habían estado cómo
le había ido a dónde comprar los boletos
yo lo sabía intuitivamente yo era su
community manager antes de que esa
palabra existiera y antes de que toda
esta industria existiera dos años
después resulta que yo universal le dan
ganas de hacer el myspace de molotov se
meten y ya existe me escriben primero
amenazado diciendo que me iban a borrar
que no que no podían y yo pues conocía
muy bien el internet de esa época y les
decían no no puede no me lo van a borrar
si quieren llegados a un trato y se los
pasó el trato fue que me ofrecieron
trabajar para ellos luego y sigue lo
llevando cuánto nos cobrás yo en ese
momento no tenía computadora no tenía
internet en mi casa yo iba a un
cibercafé a hacerlo de montados y
ciertas cosas que hacía después de
trabajar en un burger king como yo
trabajaba en el burger king y ganaba dos
mil peces que son como 100 dólares al
mes
le dije a los de molotov oye tus paga me
siendo leales pague dos mil pesos me los
dieron déjeme horrible trabajo y empecé
a trabajar con ellos poco a poco se fue
corriendo se hizo más grande myspace y
prácticamente la banda mexicana que me
digan me contactó bueno contacto amoroto
parece lo oye quien te hizo tu maestra
está muy bonito aps es un chavito cobra
dos mil pesos después de que ya
trabajaba para allison deluxe más pan
maría daniele sonido lasser fobia de
verdad del grupo que quieran cuando eran
40 bandas esos dos mil pesos ya era algo
significativo me fui a casa de mamá
tenía 19 años puse una oficina en un
departamento horrendo en la colonia roma
contraté tres amigos compré tres
computadoras y sin querer tenía lo que
yo he sería una agencia de marketing
digital cuando eso no existía no había
twitter no ven nada estoy hablando del
año 2008
empezamos a migrar a estas bandas a la
plataforma de twitter a la plataforma de
facebook cuando empezó a crecer y pasó
algo muy divertido el entonces alcalde
marcelo ebrard decide cancelar un
concierto de molotov vecindad en
el zócalo tuvo la mala fortuna del que
ahora es mi amigo de cancelar un evento
de dos clientes míos
tomo todas las cuentas de twitter que
hemos hecho y la dirección a que se
quejen de haber cancelado este concierto
evidentemente era
esto fue en 2009 twitter estaba muy
nuevo 30.000 cuentas fueron suficientes
y hoy lo golean 30.000 tuiteros
convencen a marcelo ebrard y rehacen mi
concierto de esto se da cuenta la
revista américa 2.0 los periódicos
revistas y empiezan a entrevistar me
invitan al primer community manager se
omite es la primera conferencia que doy
en 2010
ya con una industria creciente en la
siento y yo ya con la experiencia de
haber cambiado la opinión del alcalde de
una de las ciudades más grandes del
mundo a través de tweets como lo logré
yo tenía mis cuentas de los famosos y me
di cuenta que se hacía otras 10 o 20
cuentas y le escribía a las estaciones
de radio las estaciones de radio ponían
la canción que era de mi grupo
así las fui creciendo de 100 mil 10.000
logramos esto del concierto empiezo a
estar en el foco y a la hora de salir en
estos lugares
conozco a alguien del medio político
él me dice
amigo si esto que haces para estas
banditas lo hacemos en política te vas a
volver millonario ciertamente él se
volvió millonario
trabajando yo con él y después ya ya ya
vino ya vino mi oportunidad a la fecha
tenemos
ya no tenemos oficinas físicas en el
gobierno se obligó a cancelar las
llegamos a tener 17 oficinas físicas
pero hoy no tiene oficinas físicas nos
permite trabajar yo trabajo para el
gobierno de de 6 países en latinoamérica
trabajamos en tres continentes tenemos
cientos de personas trabajando en tres
idiomas haciendo lo que les voy a
presentar esta plática se llama memes de
manipulación masiva
quien controla los medios controla la
cultura qué es esto
esto lo dijo allen ginsberg hace
muchísimos años cuando los medios de
comunicación
eran los periódicos la televisión
que tenían como
que tenían como característica que era
un solo emisor
hablándole a todas las personas
cómo segmentar a la televisión a través
de sus contenidos qué es esto ponían los
anuncios para hombres durante el fútbol
porque porque asumían que viendo el
fútbol iba a ver solamente hombres
ponían los anuncios de toallas femeninas
de cosas de adolescentes en donde estaba
la novela adolescente a las 4 de la
tarde donde ya había llegado a estas
personas de la escuela y por qué
funcionaba tan bien pues porque había
solamente un perfil de mamá un perfil de
hija a todos los papás trabajaban ponían
agua sánchez ahora ponen al 'chicharito'
rasurando sean sean lampiños y la gente
lo ve lo consume y lo aceptaba
que queda que sea un solo emisor todos
los medios de comunicación incluyendo
los de ahorita
facebook twitter son empresas ya mí me
sorprende mucho que se les olvide que le
quieran exigir a una red social de
alguna libertad cuando es una empresa es
un club privado es una empresa privada
que funciona exactamente igual que la
televisión crea contenidos para atrapar
a la audiencia y exponerle un anuncio
todos absolutamente todos los medios de
comunicación viven de la publicidad que
está adentro desde el periódico más
antiguo tienen 300 años hasta si hoy tú
decides abrir un blog es para captar
gente y mostrarle un anuncio qué pasa
cuando los encargados de los demás de
comunicación son empresas porque tienen
intereses económicos
y con los cuales van a dirigir los
mensajes la televisión perdió
credibilidad
justamente por eso a mi generación no le
confían nada la televisión a pesar de
todos los filtros que hay para poder
anunciarse en televisión no le cree
porque mucho tiempo jugaron con ese
monopolio de somos lo único que puedes
ver lo único que tienes que ver y lo vas
a ver a la fuerza mi generación creció
pensando que la leche era lo mejor era
increíble porque pues porque los medios
de comunicación no lo dijeron a través
de estudios pagados por las marcas de
cereales que eran lo mejor
esto hablando en el tema comercial vean
cada anuncio de afores el afore que
están viendo es el mejor vean cada
anuncio pasta de dientes la pasta de
dientes que están viendo es la mejor y
ahí están los estudios comprobados y el
medio no está mintiendo a mí por el tipo
de trabajo que hago con los bots y las
las páginas se mi culpa es la publicidad
engañosa pero la policía engaños existe
desde que existe la publicidad desde
antes que yo naciera y para mí es igual
de engañoso estos estudios que la foto
el mcdonald's una hamburguesa que se ve
increíble y lo que te entregan es lo
mismo toda publicidad es engañosa está
hablando de lo comercial en lo que es
experto cómo funcionaba ubica en este
libro
este libro el diario ana frank que habla
que hablaba o habla de las atrocidades
cometidas por un bando fue
comercializado y expuesto por muchos
años por el otro bando no estoy diciendo
que no sea real o que no tenga algo así
del capitán américa nacido como un cómic
de propaganda para la segunda guerra
mundial y es una película que todos
disfrutamos a lo que quiero que entremos
es a la publicidad política
dentro del entretenimiento
desde antes que yo naciera para que no
me salgan con que con que yo alimente
todas las películas creo que aquí viene
más son las películas de bruce willis
avión presidencial yo crecí creyendo que
eeuu iba a salvar al mundo va a año y
medio de kobe di sigo esperando bruce
willis llegando a vacunar a cada persona
del mundo y al parecer eso no va a
suceder pero crecí creyendo que eeuu
será la potencia de lo mejor porque
porque eso es lo que proyectaban a
través de su entretenimiento y al
momento que su entretenimiento era
mundial todo mundo supo quién mandaba
ahora a quien le gustan los memes
los inocentes y hermosos - quien ha
hecho un memento por sí
veo muy poquitos y sin nadie si ustedes
no les están haciendo de donde creen que
salen los memes
porque están tan bien hechos
los memes por lo menos los más populares
salen de agencias como la mía
era peligroso que el que la televisión
pudiera enviarle un mensaje a tantas
personas tan dirigido tan
manipulable
y la televisión no tenía nada de
información de ustedes
las agencias como la mía el día de hoy a
través de sus teléfonos
tenemos toda la información que queremos
qué información tiene facebook de
ustedes
aunque ustedes le mientan y le digan que
viven en parís donde tu teléfono está de
las 10 de la noche a las 6 de la mañana
es donde me entrega a mí que vives tú
que me dice de ti dónde vives más o
menos cuánto ganas más o menos a qué te
dedicas tú le dices que trabajas en
disney no importa dónde está tu celular
de las 8 de la mañana a las 6 de la
tarde si alguien ya lo está vio como
este auditorio trabajas en este
auditorio y resulta que en este
auditorio hay 6 tipos de empleos
entonces encajas en uno de esos sueldos
y dónde vas a comer hagas o no check-in
a mí me dice usted sube muchas fotos y
muy pero la verdad come en esta fondue
está más o menos gana este rango o el no
sube muchas cosas se cuida pero sabes
qué
ghana de esta cantidad anunciarle ese
tipo de cosas habrá y los anuncios
normales en que tú le pagas a facebook
encuéntrame gente que le gusta el
chocolate que tenga 20 años se quede un
monterrey
y si te callas y el anuncio a todos
identificamos un anuncio en facebook
veo gente que no lo sabes el facebook
están hechos para que no te des cuenta a
pesar de que son intrusivos y metiches
por decirlo los de youtube son un
poquito más fáciles de identificar pero
para toda esa gente que tiene servicios
premium para quitar anuncios o que ya lo
reconoce como anuncios y los quita y no
les hace caso
existen este tipo de qantas de campañas
alguien ubica obvios teme alguna vez
lo natural sería que al estar viendo una
serie de televisión al escuchar una
canción exitosa al ver un producto que
le está yendo muy bien un personaje al
que le está yendo bien que está haciendo
bien las cosas
corriera de voz en voz la gente lo
conociera y la gente que lo conoce
sacará un meme
ese sería el proceso natural nadie se ha
dado cuenta que cuando estas series
salen antes que salga el capítulo ya
está hecho el meme nadie se pone a ver
este m/m y dice ah tal vez una campaña
del agente de streaming de estos para
que yo vea la serie nadie todos lo ven
de primera no lo entienden y el efecto
que causa es me voy a meter a ver la
serie para entender lealmente me voy a
meter a escuchar la canción para
entenderle al menos esto ya está pasando
y no solo
con
con música que puede ser inofensivo
bueno escuchaste una canción no solo con
una serie
si se dan cuenta estas campañas se usan
este es un meme
trate de que sean o no tan así pero
está hecho para contadores así hay memes
las agencias los crean
godínez
para mecánicos yo no sabía pero hay
gente que le gustan mucho los sabios y
tienen su comunidad de aves para gente
que está en la cárcel buena gente que
tune a coches para gente que le gusta
ver como otra gente tune a coches para
todos
para médicos si tú ves un meme que
cuando llega el r1 al real no le vas a
entender nada pero no va dirigido a ti
esto se mete en donde están los médicos
y ellos les gusta de esa risa
y lo comparten este es para mecánicos y
todos que se llevaron esta serie está
buena hay que ver esta serie se acuerdan
de este lo mismo es para que vieran una
película en sus caras veo que funcionó
obvio a él lo odiaron no se ven porque
ya saben fue planeado fue ustedes fueron
el objetivo de una campaña al que se le
hicieron memes específicos que jamás se
preguntaron bueno y quién se tomó el
tiempo de hacer esto
este igual todos son de la misma
plataforma
son los más obvios los que puede mostrar
aquí
pero los memes fuera del área comercial
en el área política en el área
empresarial pues puede que sean un
poquito
un signo peligrosos más dignos de que
les llamemos la atención de que estemos
atentos de que le damos las noticias y
los memes tres o cuatro veces
porque puede que haya alguien que hace
15 años trabaja en un burger king y hoy
esté vendido en millones de pesos como
manipularlos y hacerlos votar por lo que
sea
les platico rápido esta imagen logró
cambiar de votos un estado completo en
eeuu porque la estrategia del contrario
fue poner es uno de los estados más
obesos de eeuu y los contrarios apelando
a la razón apelando al conocimiento
pusieron a la gente a correr pusieron a
la gente a que comiera menos recetas de
ensaladas como comer sano
pero él y su equipo que conocen
conocemos a los gorditos no queremos que
nos hablen de eso que hizo él subió esta
foto
comiendo una de las empresas más
nacionalistas y que más engordan que que
simuló el poder más grande ahí para un
estadounidense
que un multimillonario en su avión
privado comiendo lo que le da la gana
esto los en poder o les llegó al corazón
y cambio completamente los votos de un
estado y si creen que esto no ha llegado
aquí
tengan mucho cuidado
revisen bien todo lo que les aparece en
internet porque nada de eso es
casualidad muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]